c'est tout naturellement chez émir la
troisième de cette fratrie de quatre
enfants que toute la famille de france
norbert s'est réuni le noyau dur c'est à
dire ses trois soeurs sa maman est le
compagnon demir les visages sont graves
les voix sont blanches et l'inquiétude
est immense le pire c'est certainement
l'incertitude france norbert connaît
bien la mère sa passion il n'est pas
pêcheur professionnel et avait arrêté de
partir en mer depuis près d'un an déjà
affaibli par la drépanocytose n'est pas
la première fois la première fois qu'il
y a que l'état aidé et après comment
c'est que ces cas six jours oui les
autres et l'espoir est grand pau 3
norbert est donc parti de sainte-luce
mercredi au petit matin avec daniel
florian vers un dcp un dispositif à
concentration de poissons
les conditions de navigation étaient
difficiles laguiole aurait chaviré à
cause d'une déferlante
le capitaine a été retrouvé hier en fin
d'après-midi en vie accroché à la coque
du bateau france norbert aurait disparu
dans la nuit de mercredi à jeudi alors
qu'il était lui aussi accroché à
laguiole nous sommes accablés
nous nous posons la question qu'est ce
qui s'est passé nous disons comment ça
va aller
on va aller on va les retrouver on va le
retrouver parce que quand même
on a retrouvé un donc gardons espoir que
qu'ils seront encore en vie que les
autos mythique compétents vont faire ce
qu'il faut on est faisant confiance ce
matin l'hélicoptère de la gendarmerie et
l'avion des douanes ont repris les
recherches objectif quadrillé
entièrement la zone de la côte au vent
aujourd'hui mais pour l'instant restent
toujours sans nouvelles de france
norbert